hi hello everybody
um
so this is uh this will be a talk about
sketching complexity of graph cards and
this is joint work with robbie croft
gamer and david woodruff
who you have just seen
okay
so
let me start so before i mean this is
about a particular result about a
particular construction uh but i mean
just to kind of put places in the
context kind of you know where the
question comes from i mean i just want
to spend kind of two quick very quick
slides from kind of slightly bigger
picture
of what's happening and
what's happening is in general kind of
we we may be curious about the questions
of graph compression uh which means that
we have a big graph
we want to construct a smaller graph
such that this smaller graph somehow
looks like the big graph
right and
i mean
i guess here kind of my picture i'm kind
of suggesting actually you know smaller
number of edges smaller number of
vertices i mean we will talk only about
smaller number of hedges here but you
know in general kind of as a general
principle you can think about smaller
graphs and then you begin to you know of
course the question is what um
why do we want to do it i mean there are
why do we care about smaller graphs uh
of course there are maybe many
applications uh one that you know
sherlick and france through as a theme
in this entire workshop is faster
algorithms once you construct smaller
graphs you know groups become faster
um also in other applications you may
want smaller graphs because you want to
use less storage to just you know
represent this graph uh sometimes some
other applications it's if your graph is
much much smaller but it's usually
easier to visualize or to play with if
you want to kind of discover some
properties like a social graph or
something like that
okay and the you know of course you know
i put some squiggly here saying you know
that you know roughly approximates and
of course you know the main question is
you know what what do we mean exactly by
these approximates and in general you
want you know you think about this as
preserving some kind of structure
um so for example one particular
structure that we will be talking here
and you know runs the theme
in our talks uh is to preserve the
structure of the cuts so what i want is
that
i'll construct the uh another graph on
the same set of vertices so that the cut
values are approximated
are equal where approximately usually
just to obtain smaller graphs usually in
approximation
uh but in general you can imagine other
properties like distances flows
electrical conductors and so forth
okay so you know this is just you know
placing in a bigger context i mean i'll
focus here on cuts okay
um
all right so
for cuts from definition
i i'm sure all of you know the
definition but you know just to put it
on the same page uh so we have a graph g
with n nodes m edges
we want to construct another graph we
call it h
so that for any set s
of vertices the cut
in graph g
is roughly
well approximated by the cutting graph h
on the same set and
approximated we'll think about one
perception approximation
okay standard definition of of cuts
partifiers
okay so um and you know very classic
results is uh venture cargo from 96
which says that we can construct a graph
h which
has the number of edges is only n
divided by epsilon squared times a log
factor
okay so we can start from potentially
quadratic size graph to something which
is n divided by epsilon squared times
log n
and you know the general apologies to
sample edges in the graph
um this sampling has to be non-uniform
so we cannot just take all the edges and
just uniformly sample them um you know
is this counter example you know it's a
classic counter example why we cannot do
this
um and you know of course the question
is how exactly do we do sampling here
and you know in some sense this is the
main question in this line of work
um and there are many ways of to sample
edges uh according to different notions
of connectivity in the graph um
and uh
and all of all of these all of these
results which sample edges will in
general
as i mentioned we can use this to speed
up cut problems and in general all
specifiers will obtain the size which is
n divided by epsilon squared some times
some
polylog so some of them will obtain logs
some of them will obtain log squared
maybe
but in general this is the type of
result that you obtain there are this
kind of approaches of course there is a
question of can we do better
and the answer is yes there is beautiful
paper master spiel mercedes tower who
proved that you can get rid of your
polylog factors okay so you can obtain
the number of edges only and divided by
epsilon squared
and it is actually a deterministic
algorithm
okay
so
um
okay so this is i mean
okay so what's next kind of uh
so there is a dependence on epsilon okay
so what what we have is we have a
dependence on epsilon which is quadratic
so it is n divided by epsilon squared
and it is natural to ask you know is
this dependence quadratic dependence on
one over epsilon necessary
um in general you know factor of one
over epsilon if you think of epsilon's
like
you know one percent can be more
expensive than a log factor um but you
know think about kind of theoretically
can we be this one over epsilon squared
uh factor
and uh in general it seems to ha it
seems hard to avoid one over epsilon
squared so there are some
some lower balancing but at least for
spectral specification which is a
generalization of the cost specification
so for a harder problem at least you do
need n divided by epsilon squared so
this is optimal
okay um
and uh
i mean still kind of you know first of
all you know okay this is for a harder
problem and you know maybe for our
casper safari we can actually get and
divided by epsilon you know these
worthwhile to to at least verify this to
to see
um
and also
i mean algorithmically and i'll get back
to this issue but algorithmically if you
look at the lower bound
you know from from the kind of as an an
algorithm this time not particularly
satisfied
by these lower bounds because this lower
bound say that what if you have a
complete graph and you want to come to
construct a small specifier you cannot
beat the n divided by epsilon squared
size
but if it is for a complete graph i mean
i know exactly what are we cut values
right it is not it is not a satisfying
lower bond right it is not something
that
i know exactly what are we called values
right
so
uh so you know at least maybe for
applications we can you know change the
notion a little bit or
somehow you know go go around that
okay so let me you know just state the
results uh so again for the customer
service problem uh so first of all we
prove a lower one that says that yes
indeed for cost perspires and divided by
epsilon square size is necessary
okay so
you know just answering the question yes
it is even for this in some sense
simpler problem and divided by 1 squared
is necessary
uh
on the upper bound side we show that
actually if you change the notion
what exactly we mean by cut specifier we
can
we can obtain a dependence which is just
and one by epsilon
so in particular we'll give a
construction that gives uh
a size when divided by epsilon times 40
log
for a relaxed notion what does the relax
notion means there are two relaxations
so one relaxation is that instead of a
graph h where you know we compute
the cuts in the usual value we will
construct a sketch which you think you
can think about as a data structure you
know it doesn't look like a graph but
something else and it works the
following way uh you give a set s to it
you tell it set s it outputs you know
things uh outputs uh the cut
off s right and this value cut s is one
perception approximation of the original
cut in the graph g okay and this sketch
has this size okay and divided by
epsilon polylog
so this is relaxation one realization
two uh is that for every
cut s so think about this is a data
structure which is high probability of
success so for each set s it will answer
these you know will have this guarantee
with high probability
instead of
all cuts at the same time right so for a
graph you don't think about this kind of
randomized guarantee so you know for
those who know kind of the difference
of for each versus for all is let's say
in complex sensing this is exactly this
difference
um this is a kind of for each guarantee
okay
um are there questions about
statements yes
work for that or not
don't worry who trees work for what is
that i thought there was a tree for
which
you get exact cuts right
mean cuts between st
this is for all all cards i give a set s
and i want card value of the status
um
other questions
okay so let me give kind of you know run
from motivating example in particular
say you know why relaxation goes around
with let's say complete graph so you
know let's let's look at complete graph
kind of and see why
you know why kind of in standard notion
we kind of need one over epsilon squared
as opposed to why in this sketch we can
we can get around with one over epsilon
squared mount okay so suppose that we
sample each edge of probability
something like s divided by n which
means that uh the degree of each node in
particular will be something like s plus
minus root s this is just standard
deviation
uh which you can you know just write it
in you know kind of what is a
multiplicative approximation it is a
multiplicative approximation is one plus
minus one over root s
right so if we consider vector vertex
cuts right then in some sense we need l
to set s to be roughly one over epsilon
square to guarantee a one perception
approximation
you know even with constant probability
for for a particular vertex cut
right um you know of course you can
answer ask the question maybe there is
another way to kind of do the sampling
and the answer is that no in general you
cannot really do other types of sampling
this is the best you can do if you
really want to construct a graph
uh
and
on the other hand you know again kind of
coming to this intuition okay if it is a
complete graph then
you know i can just let's say store the
degrees of the i mean the degrees of all
nodes or you know for complete graph i
know exactly what really cut values i
don't really need to store anything
and uh
you know so i can store for example
if you imagine this as being half for
example right then you know storing the
degrees makes sense um
but uh
you know of course you can ask like okay
there are other cuts and for other cards
you may need to store other you know you
need to store more numbers but if you
are to consider let's say very big cuts
kind of which cut the graph roughly half
when the number of edges uh
there is roughly n squared and if we
sample we sample from a much larger pool
so we have a much better approximation
so for both cars we shouldn't care about
this here's a question the weight of
each age is one
in the original graph yes
the lower bounds hold even if the
resulting graph is weighted so
but the procedure that you're going to
show will hold also for weighted yes yes
absolutely yeah
okay yeah the algorithm our construction
upper bound will work for weighted
graphs as well i mean okay you will need
the number of
i mean the representation will will
depend on log of a max on the aspect
ratio okay
you have edges which are very big you
might need to store those values at
least so
but
okay so
so this is the example um
okay so
you know this is this is where the
statement results in tuition now i'll
actually give you construction
any questions so far
no okay so the upper bound so i'll give
you construction uh the the description
of the construction is composed of three
parts uh i will describe the sketch
basically how do we construct the sketch
will actually look like a sample of a
graph
more or less to be a sample of a graph
it will still kind of sample edges but
in slightly different way plus a little
bit more information uh i'll show that
the sketch size is you know what we
claim to be in particular this prologue
is log squared
and then i'll show how to do how to use
the sketch to estimate the cut values
and you know essentially give an
intuition why this works
and i'll focus on the weighted graph so
but the extension is simple especially
but we have a sketch
um okay so with this sketch construction
so it it will fit on this slide um
let's go slowly for it so there are
three steps in the construction
so step number one is uh
we will guess a course cut value v so
what it does mean course course means
after approximation factor two
okay um
and uh once suppose suppose we know the
cut value after approximation factor two
right let's this value this
approximation be v so let's fix this v
and say that our our cut that we want to
estimate uh i mean we don't know it at
the moment but you know what we want to
estimate will be roughly value v
what we do is we downsample all the
edges uniformly probability one over
epsilon squared times one over v
basically this means that
all the cuts of value roughly v will
become a value roughly one of one over
epsilon squared
okay
and in general what does it mean to
guess i mean you'll prepare for all
possible values of v and there's only
log n of these values question
probability is independent of the weight
of the edge there is the graph is
unweighted
so i'll say the upper bound applies for
weighted
it is it does apply for weighted i'm
describing here just the unweighted case
if you i mean yes i can i mean
extension to the weighted case is is
relatively simple actually we can
prepare
you know build a sparsifier for each
potential kind of group of weights
for example
or do some important sampling
this construction is from weighted but
the modifications for the weighted case
are are minor
okay um
okay so now uh so this is so yeah
this is step number one step number two
is what we do is we decompose a graph
along sparse cuts uh what is a sparse
cut basically in any connected component
so this is a iterative procedure in any
connected component c even exists a
subset p such of let's say it must have
the size such that the cut value of p
in the sample graph is that was
something like one over epsilon times p
right so this is a you know sparse cut
of sparsity one over epsilon when
we store these cut edges basically
along the sparse cut we store these
edges separately we delete them from the
graph and repeat on the remaining graph
okay
part three in the remaining graph so
after we have performed this
right we we
we have a bunch of connected components
which do not have any sparse cuts in
this definition
uh so what we remember is essentially
the connectivity structure right what
are the connected components the degrees
of each node
and for each node we sample
one of our epsilon edges
outgoing edges
note that we can do the sample just
because we know that the degree of each
non-isolated vertex has to be at least
one over epsilon otherwise it is in a
sparse cut
and just to make sure what
what this sketch actually stores it
stores this cut cross-cut edges
while we are performing this procedure
and basically this information meaning
the density the the connectivity after
we remove sparse cuts the degrees of all
nodes and a sample of one over epsilon
edges out of each node
is this sketch clear
right so basically step number one says
let's kind of normalize the graphs over
the
so would be cut value is roughly around
one over epsilon squared then we
decompose along sparse cuts and remember
these edges crossing the sparse cuts in
step number three we essentially just
remember the connectivity structure the
degrees
and a sample of one over epsilon edges
from each node
okay so let me even go for uh
talk about sketch size
so basically
you know just just summarizing what we
store uh we store the edges across
sparse cuts we store no degrees with no
degrees in you know connectivity
structure and a sample of one over
epsilon edges out of each node
okay so we want to show that this is
bounded but this is undivided by epsilon
times body log
and you know this is obviously takes
essentially order and space uh well
order and words
um
sample takes
sampling one over epsilon edges takes
and divided by epsilon space
so what remains is this first part and
for this first part we can prove
it's a relatively simple claim that the
that edges across parse cuts are only n
divided by epsilon times log n
there's only that many
uh
edges across the sparse cuts
okay and we'll prove his claim no
this one
okay
so in step two do you recursively do it
because when you cut the graph then it
could be the pieces now have to be cut
again
precisely we'll keep doing it until the
piece is no longer happening
yes yes so this is this is this is
recursive yes thank you for your
question
yeah and i mean once we cut the graph
there could be new sparse cuts
with that start appearing
once we
continue this process
okay so it is a in some sense very
iterative procedure
any other questions about the
construction that's pretty important
right for them
um okay
okay so let me
prove this claim that the number of
edges across the sparse cut
is only n by epsilon times level
um
so first once we found the sparse cut
right uh we store at most uh you know
the number the number of vertices in on
one side
times one over epsilon edges this is
just by definition of the
uh of the sparsity
right
um
now
what we'll do i mean we'll use a
charging argument a simple charging
argument and we say we'll charge these
edges to the nodes in this set p
okay so once once a node participates in
such a sparse cut it will get assigned
one of our epsilon edges
okay but what happens is that once a
node is charged this means that it's
participating in the sparse cut
this means that the size of its
connected component
decreased by a factor at least two
perhaps much more but at least by factor
two which means that a node in
particular can be charged only logan
times
overall space is essentially you know
just summing up everything it's n by
epsilon times log n and this log n is
just for the guessing part
so guessing the value
edges after you remove the sparse cut
or in the original graph
so can you repeat the question uh the
stamp of one of the rational edges out
of each serve this one right is it after
you remove the sparse cuts precisely
precisely yeah yeah so
again you do uniform sampling at the
beginning
when you remove along with sparse cuts
iteratively until there is no more
sparse cuts
once you are done that
you store these and you store a sample
of one of the reps on edges out of each
note
okay but you don't combine it into a
single graph you keep using separate
data structures
we think i mean you can think about this
as a as a graph i mean of course the
edges across the sparse cuts is a graph
the sample is a graph but we will treat
them differently those edges here
i mean we know which edge came from
which part
and we'll treat them differently so it
will be clear from the estimation
procedure how and what
okay so it remains to describe
estimation um okay so now so we have
done all the sampling we remember all
this information now we're given a set s
we need to estimate the cut value of s
okay
so
uh
again uh just by assumption kind of by
guessing assumption v is a factor two
guess of the cut value of s
um
so the estimate will be
basically some normalization term times
the sum of
two terms um
one term is the number of sparse cuts
sparse cut edges in in the participating
in the cutters basically crossing from s
to not s
okay
and part the other term uh will have you
know itself a few terms basically for
each dense component what it will do it
will 70 degrees uh inside um
s intersection c will be a picture on
the next slide i'm just you know
describing roughly how it looks like so
i mean the picture will have a lot of
components so
i first want to give the simple uh
kind of a simple description so for each
dance component what happens is that
normally if you if your sketch is
actually a graph what you do is you have
a cut you'll just count the number of
edges crossing the cut
what we are saying here is that there is
a different estimate
we can which will give you this namely
you count the the sum of the degrees
inside the the one side of the set
and you and then you subtract the
estimate of the number of edges inside
with uh
inside the set okay
so note that this in some sense is
deterministic quantity right there is i
mean model of the original sampling from
sampling but
some of the degrees with degrees we
store it precisely whereas this is the
part that uses these sampled edges
the the one over epsilon sample out of
each node
okay so let me um
this normalization is just epsilon
squared times z
um
just to get a basically horizontal
estimator
okay so estimation illustration this is
just you know writing in formula what i
said on the previous slide will be a
picture here
the the color coding will correspond to
the picture
um
so um
okay so this is i mean just let's
introduce a little bit of notation so
so basically this is our graph
after we have removed the sparse edges
okay so basically each of these blue
blobs is the dense component which
doesn't have any sparse cuts inside
uh this is our set s right it cuts a few
of them let's say
uh so let we denote by c one of these
blue components these dense components
uh sc is essentially intersection of the
c with set s so basically this is this
part
okay so basically this now introduces
all the notation um so for each dense
component we will sum up the degrees of
nodes inside with this part uh minus the
estimate you know this is just a
normalization term
um
estimate of the number of edges internal
edges here
okay this is uh this is this estimate
which is computed from the num from the
edges that are sampled
okay so
uh
basically just you know just vectorially
kind of will be some a number of edges
that you know go everywhere
uh the edges that
these the green edges are the edges that
that participate in these in this term
okay the black edges don't participate
in this in the sum
uh and the red edges participate in this
uh in this sum
okay so all the uh
remember that the structure remembers
kind of the edges across as well as a
sample of number of edges from each node
okay
does the estimation procedure make sense
no okay how do you store all the edges
uh
you store all the edges in the sparse
cut but not all the edges in the sparse
cut participate in your estimate
okay so
there are two there are two types of
edges right that are stored the edges
that are across the sparse cut and the
edges that are sampled from each node
okay
so
the edges that are stored for spar
across sparse cuts will participate in
this in this green term remain or may
not participate
and the sampled edges participate in
this in this estimate
in this red estimate
okay in some sense
think about this that uh normally
if you take a graph and we sample the
number of edges or somehow remember a
number of hinges from it the normal the
normal estimate
right
you can think about like as cut
specifier in the usual sense where we
have just a graph as
it is an estimation procedure given a
graph and it says that i have a set s i
you know basically draw this line and i
see and i count the number of edges that
that crossed that line
okay so this is one way to do estimate
there is another way to do estimate
namely count the number of edges inside
the so count the degrees sum of the
degrees of the nodes of the nodes inside
s minus the number of edges which are
internal here
this is another estimate of the number
of edges that go across
okay and basically we use in some sense
two estimates and one is the first type
of estimate is used for the cross cut
edges for for the
edges that
cross with sparse cuts and the second
type of estimate is used
for edges inside
lens components
so
at least
i mean
at least it should be obvious but the
expectation of this
gives us the right cut value
i mean i need to argue to you that
why doing this is better and namely we
will show that the variance of these
is better than the variance of the other
of the normal estimate
but at least in the you know kind of you
know when you construct an estimate or a
probabilistic estimator first for
somebody you know first thing you should
check but it is not biased right or or
if your bias is very small
the expectation
of your output is equal to
the right value
because inside
inside the component you're denser than
the across the cadets
in a sensor
i mean i yes
at least this is a good question to ask
i'll i'll explain in the next couple
slides why variance is better
but
this is the right question
are there any other questions so far
okay
um
okay so let me uh
basically correctness compose of three
steps two of them will be simple the
third one will be you know the heart of
the matter uh so we need to prove that
uh each of these over three steps will
preserve the cut value after
approximation one plus epsilon so you
know the first step was to down sample
down to
one over epsilon cut value right so we
said like we guessed that the value is
something like that we sample down
the the edges uniformly so that the cut
value from v becomes one over epsilon
squared and
you know just very kind of the usual
sampling and the phenomenon sampling
says but if we sample down to something
like one over epsilon squared items then
the
multiplicative approximation is one plus
epsilon
okay so the first step
says that for our cut value the the
approximation that we introduced is only
one plus epsilon
okay
so
step step two i mean basically this is
the green part right uh what is the its
error well
since we store the edges across the
sparse cuts
exactly we know exactly what we are
there is no more sampling there is no
more additional approximation introduced
so the only i mean the one additional
thing that we need to verify is that the
edges inside computing this red sum
right of edges inside the dense
component introduces that most of one
perception approximation
okay so this will be and you know as
already pointed out but
i mean the idea here is to show that the
estimate of the number of edges inside s
has less variance than if you were to
use the normal estimator namely the
number of hedges across the cut using
this sample
okay so
and here i mean here is the intuition
basically uh the intuition is the
following so
uh the number of uh so let's let's
concentrate on that component only right
just forget about everything else let's
focus on this third part we have a dense
component we need to show that but then
component has a multiplicative one
perception approximation
uh
so
the number of crosscut edges basically
so this is a dense component this is the
set s this is our set p so this is the
inside
um
so the number of edges that cross the
cut can be of value roughly one over
epsilon squared
right it cannot be much more first of
all just because of the first step where
we normalize the cut value to one over
epsilon squared so it cannot be much
more
now the problem why doesn't why doesn't
normal estimator work why sampling one
over epsilon edges from each node does
not work it is because we can have one
node that has this one over epsilon
degree one represents squared degree and
always i mean if we just sample one over
epsilon edges out of this node we will
just not have a good variance for this
estimator
okay so the problem is you know really
kind of in the extreme case we have one
node big degree everything goes on on
the side and that will have bad variance
yes so
i'm gonna confuse why this if i happen
for one note but not for two notes
like does it just taper off so quickly
i'm just showing kind of a bad example
in some sense one notice of the worst
case that doesn't mean that
yes but but your sketch your sketch
seems to handle the one note case as a
very special case
because it's room it's recording it's
it's recording the degrees sure yeah i
mean i'm just
um
well the estimator you know does not
think about this as one node or many
nodes right
think of it as doing the same thing for
two nodes it's like showing the out
degree for the total attribute instead
of two nodes it only differs by the you
know one it's like the degree of one
plus the degree of the other minus one
so he's really not so it's like it's
almost the same as having for all small
sets storing the sun number valley edges
for those sets
yeah but that's a great explanation
uh so we kind of i mean one one idea
would be to say that the set is so small
but the number of edges inside is so
small but it is insignificant so this is
not the case but the but we can but this
com this number can be estimated well
from our one over you know sample of one
over epsilon edges per node
okay and basically what we show that
there is no such issue for internal no
for internal edges uh why first we will
show that this set s is small it is
something like one over epsilon which
means that
each node cannot have a big internal
degree
right so basically to have this to have
a large number of edges this means that
we have to be supported by many nodes
but if you have many nodes when we have
many more samples
right each node comes with you know some
edges and a budget of samples so the
more samples we take the better the
variance becomes
okay so let me let me show at least the
part number one that this set is small
um
so
and and i mean in some sense somewhere
we need to use that to use sparse cuts
no not just for the size but also for
the estimator right and this is where it
comes
um
so uh my set uh sc is uh so yeah i want
to say that at least for dense component
if we look at the set it is small
why it is so first you know there are
two statements one is that uh the cut
the cut value has to be at least one
over epsilon times a c because this was
not a sparse cut
on the other hand the cut value of a c
is at most something like 2 divided by
epsilon squared just because we get the
the right cut value after factor 2.
putting this together gives us an upper
bound on the size of this set
okay
that's really
um
okay so now
i mean i'm not gonna do the computation
but i mean this is really the intuition
that i explained um but now if you take
this sum you compute this the
its variance this variance will be
something like you know order epsilon
times the cut value
okay but intuition is really
because we cannot i mean
if there's many edges inside this
component inside this set sc
large number of internal edges they have
to be supposed to do many nodes will be
many samples to use
okay um
okay so just to do basically our warm-up
and basically these finishes we estimate
are there other questions about the
estimate
or the correctness proof
um okay so
you know you finish this by you know
doing a variance calculation um
and
you know you can get a high probability
bound by repeating this and say that we
are doing a medium estimator this is a
sketch we can do a lot of algorithmic
stuff actually um
so
one node that i should mention that in
the construction we use sparse cuts okay
so
you know it looks like preprocessing
should be you know exponential time
because we're solving a big heart
problem uh the cool part here is that it
is one of these kind of nice situations
where doing approximation
is actually okay because it will
translate into the size
so if we do alpha approximation for
sparse cuts then uh these these loss of
alpha will just go in size
okay uh so if for example we will use
the
you know
fastest uh sparse cut uh construction uh
by alexander mandari at least that i
know of um
then in general we
we will obtain something like runtime
which is mn to power one plus delta
and the space will be n by epsilon times
the body log this 40 log power depends
on delta
you are not actually computing star
looking for a partition a card
so that the number of edges
is less than or equal to one over
epsilon times the number of
nodes on one side
you can do that in polynomial time if
epsilon is constant
what do you mean epsilon is all constant
well i mean i uh so
you're asking the question for an
epsilon right right
i i think of episode i
perhaps i mean
okay so this is i mean this is one
option top approaching sorry
the computation of that is done in
strongly polynomial time it's
independent of the value of epsilon
is it
okay
yeah
i can show you later
so why i mean why doesn't it solve a
sparse cut problem then or because in
the spouse cut you have a
restriction well i don't know exactly
how you define spouse card but
you have a here you don't
which side will be less than or equal to
half
right
one side is always going to be less than
or equal to half i want the smaller side
the smaller side to have this so that's
like expanding
it's like expander yeah okay okay so
that's how yeah okay
um
okay so
let me show just okay so
you know this is a sketch now the
question is you know we relax some
things i mean is it still useful right i
mean one of the ideas was to okay let's
let's try to speed up things right and
uh let me show you an application uh for
this
um definitely interesting to to see more
applications but you know just to give
you one application and it is more in in
the realm of uh space limited uh
algorithms basically streaming sketching
type algorithms
um and the idea is to do sketching for
global mean cut so imagine the situation
where you have a big graph it is say
distributed over many agents many
computers and each computer has to
compute a sketch of of each part of a
graph sent to a central node and that
central node needs to compute the global
mean cut of the union of the graphs
uh so this is a theorem statement for
two part for a partition of two
but um in general it says that we can
compute a sketch of a graph g of size n
by epsilon times four logs so that you
know given sketches of two graphs g one
and g two this is enough to compute the
mean cut of the union of g one and g two
um
obviously it stands to move into
partitions uh and just to mention that
you know basically a lot of uh
very nice al work on streaming
algorithms for computing uh sparsifier
cutter and spectra of specifiers will
get a one over epsilon squared
dependence on epsilon as opposed to and
by epsilon
okay so
the previous approaches to computing the
global mean cut just to make sure um
okay so how do we do this um
very simple uh basically what we'll do
we'll store two cut specifiers one is is
our relaxed one
and second is we will store a classic
sparsifier which is kind of a graph for
all uh but which works for say constant
approximation something like 1.5
approximation
okay and this will i mean since epsilon
is a constant this takes only analog and
space
um
and now the idea is
why is this enough right so
so david cargill proved
nice theorem saying that
um
there is only
polynomial number of cuts which are
within a factor of 1.5 of a global mean
cut
okay
so
so we can list all such cuts
using
this
this parsifier
okay this list will include the actual
global mean cut
and for each each of these each of the
potential cuts in this list of n cubed
cuts uh we can verify it or estimate it
up top one plus epsilon approximation
using the relaxed sparsifier
the basic idea is that
the sketch is good wherever wherever you
are doing a polynomial number of
non-adaptive samples oh we estimate
queries
okay this is this is very
okay um
so
let me switch gears let's go to the
lower bound
uh are there other upper bound uh
questions about upper bounds
yeah i
can you show again how you get this
expanders that is you know checking
whether there is an expanded less than
or equal
to one over epsilon y okay
how do you do that uh
i missed
how you doing
uh so we will use an alpha approximation
for this uh how do we do this i mean
there are much better experts than me in
this audience so i won't even try to at
them say i mean there are you know like
log n approximation
so alpha could be log n here alpha can
be log n here yes so this alpha which is
log n will go into
the size
just
you know
just going through the proof it should
be simple to see that you know if we
just overestimate basically the number
of edges is a little bit more by factor
of alpha we just store
more of these edges in this
second part where we store the edges
across sparse cuts
so what are the bounds so
i mean
so this is why the size will increase by
a factor of alpha
depends on i mean there is a trade-off
between the run time to compute this
approximation and the approximation
uh so in particular if you want near
linear time when we need to go to log to
power
to a bigger power
so
one issue that can happen if you use an
approximate sparse cut
is
isn't it possible that you still need to
do recursion on
both sides
so but if you get a really small sparse
cut and the big size is big how do you
bound your recursion that is why it is a
man
ah okay
yes yes
okay
no good very good point yeah i mean it'd
be nice to make it an actual linear time
algorithm here right or at least you
know n to one plus zero
okay lower bound so let me kind of show
the principle of the lower bound at
least
so
um
so i mean in general of course the
question kind of you know before kind of
stating the actual theorem you know the
question that should be asked okay we
had two relaxations obviously relaxation
is necessary okay what were the
relaxations one is that for instead of a
graph h we're using a sketch edge so
it's a data structure and this is one
part two is that each cut s is preserved
with high probability a buff of is
necessary i don't know about this one
for this one we propel our bond
uh and in particular we say that
so it is it is not
only a graph size lower bond it is an
actual information theoretical bond
saying that the amount of information
that it needs to be stored to be able to
sketch uh every cut s
without any probability right i mean
with probability one uh
this requires n divided by epsilon
squared bits
okay i mean this can
this can also be used to prove that the
actual graph size actually has to be n
by epsilon squared as well for casper
sapphire but you know this is what we
focus i mean sometimes this is a more
it's a stronger theorem
okay
and the proof goes really via
communication complexity
okay
and
we really kind of you know
kind of thinking about it what has to
happen in this lower bound is that we
really need to use the fact that h
will be able to ask an exponential
number
of cut queries
okay all right so uh so let me do proof
outline let me set up kind of how
approve how a lower bound proof looks
like so
it is until 12 right
okay um
no it's okay i mean at least to give an
impression of israel it should be enough
uh
so let me set up just you know some
parameters so that you know it
simplifies the problem a little bit so
let me set up epsilon to be something
like one over root and
r is uh essentially one over epsilon but
it will appear somewhere a little bit
later um
so basically what we want to prove is
that you know note that n by epsilon
squared now really looks like n squared
so
so we want to prove that for this
setting of epsilon but we need n squared
bits omega n squared bits
okay uh so communication complexity let
me show up uh how this looks like uh so
this is our supercomputer alice well not
our but leicester university computer
alice and this is bob um
and
it really kind of shows that
the amount of information that or input
that they get will actually be different
uh
so let's so let me because i'm setting
up a communication problem okay so let
me describe what it is so alice
which has lots of storage uh
will will have as input and strings
uh each is a hamming
vector of length n
okay so there's a total of n squared
bits
bob
has much less information it has a
string
which is a
hamming vector of length n and then
index between 1 and n
in xk
um so now
you know we need to solve a problem
by communication this is the this is the
problem that we need to
solve
we need to distinguish whether the
delta stands for hamming distance
whether the hamming distance between the
string t that bob has and sk so
basically it uses
this this index k this index k to index
one of the strings that alice has and we
need to check we need to compute in some
sense the hamming distance between t and
this indexed string as k and we need to
check whether the distance is
essentially
large or small
where basically these strings are close
or far let me use this terminology and
close means that this is less than
you know so think about the strings as
being random right um
so with some constant probability it is
less than uh n by half minus standard
deviation versus n by half plus standard
deviation
or you know order standard deviation so
this is bizarre right this is bizarre is
roughly root n
okay
uh so this is the problem to to solve
how do we solve it basically alice sends
a bunch of information to bob
and the
the information cost is essentially how
many bits are needed to be
sent
okay so this is a communication problem
um
so what what we'll do is that
we will show how to solve this
communication problem
assuming that we have a
a solution for the sketch problem
okay for the cut sketch problem
and then a lower bound on this problem
which
i guess i'm calling index of gap ham
of gap hamming uh then a lower bond for
these for this problem the communication
complexion hormone for this problem will
imply a lower bound on the size of h
okay in particular we'll show that you
know alice cannot do much more than send
its entire information basically n
squared you know order n squared
information um and this will
mean that h also has to have size which
is roughly n squared
okay does this make sense
okay
um
okay so what is i mean
why it is called kind of index gap
hamming well it is essentially an unfold
of game having problem gap hamming
problem is really where alice just has
one string of length and bob has another
string of length n um and you need to
distinguish this basically close or far
basically you know half distance minus
under variation versus half distance
half plus standard deviation and you
know this is a
very nice problem you know people sell
it a lot and
that particular problem requires size n
and it is in some sense an index of this
gap hamming where it says that uh
we are not solving this problem but bob
has an index k and it has to solve the
case
gap hamming problem
okay so in some sense it's a combination
of index and gap hamming
you know
okay so there is one
kind of uh
sometimes technical issue that
there is a particular distribution um
and the distribution is such that i mean
we need a lower bound for a particular
distribution just because of you know we
are later doing a reduction uh and in
particular uh
we
the distribution is such that all these
strings are random uh
conditioned on uh
on this delta satisfying one of the two
conditions
um
plus it should say that all the strings
have exactly weight and by two
and then one has to prove that this
requires n squared communication
i'm not gonna
go into details how to prove such n
squared communication lower bound
but
think about this as combining two
problems which are kind of very
fundamental communication complexity one
is indexing problem which essentially
requires full communication gap hamming
which requires full communication
it shouldn't be surprising that the
recommendation requires
n-squared communication
um
okay so now i mean what what i will show
uh is how to read how to reduce this
problem basically so assuming that this
problem index kept hamming requires n
squared size uh what we want to do is
that we will show that you know if we if
we can solve this cut sketch uh problem
that we can solve this problem as well
and you know the idea is really kind of
to do some kind of embedding of one
problem into the other
in particular uh alice and bob uh will
use this cut sketch construction uh to
solve their problem with index of gap
hamming uh and network the following way
so we need to construct some graphs of
course right
so alex will construct alice will
construct a graph g which will have two
n nodes so
sorry for switching from n to n uh but
it just simplifies because the
description um and what it will do is it
will compute the sketch you know
assuming that there is a sketch
algorithm for g it will compute with uh
cut sketch h
some data structure
of g and send that information basically
the data structure to bob
okay
and then bob will use h to decide on
this problem on this communication
problem
okay so uh pictorially uh alice bob
uh so alice construct a graph g of two
of nodes given its strings s1 up to sn
how it is constructed this is the
picture
more or less should be kind of uh
self-evident but this is so this is a
situation for n equals four we have a
bipartite graph uh
n nodes on one on left side
n nodes on the right side uh on left
hand side
nodes will correspond to the string s
and these will correspond to the n
coordinates and basically the edges
correspond to the bits that are set to
one
okay so in particular the degree say of
each node here will be exactly and by
two
okay now bob
okay so we construct the sketch
h send it to bob
now bob what it does it has a string t
of length n it constructs a set t on the
right hand side
so for example
you know again kind of using this binary
representation kind of encoding so if t
is equal to 0 0 1 1 this corresponds to
the last two nodes right being in the
set t this is the definition of set t
and then what it does
is the following it computes a set s
of size n by two
that minimizes on the left hand side
that minimizes
the cut value of s union t
right
so
you know here is one example of such
of of a set s it was it consists of one
and three
uh and basically what it does it
it finds this set uh
of you know half the size on the left
hand side
that minimizes its cut value
or put differently it maximizes the
number of edges that are inside
okay so intuitively this this chooses
this the strings
that have
smaller
hamming distance
to my to my string t
right modulo all the approximations and
stuff what it intuitively does it really
chooses the the
uh the strings that are
that have smaller hamming distance
to city and basically and indeed kind of
at the end bob outputs that we are close
if this if this index k is inside the
set s that has been chosen to minimize
this
um i see some puzzle phases why didn't
bob just take a look at
it knows k right so why don't bob just
look at sk and count the number of edges
between sk i cannot count the number of
edges because i have a sketch which just
tells me the cut values right
oh okay i see and that is not a good
estimate right precisely
okay
so yes if i just take this and i take sk
and i look at the cut value the cut
value will be very large right so large
that the standard deviation on it will
swamp out your attempt to count number
of internal edges this is okay
yeah
okay
and i mean in some think about this as
inside it couldn't have worked
because
uh for that question if this is what bob
asks then this relaxed cut specifier
would have worked actually because it is
just one non-adaptive query
it works with hyper-ability
right
okay so
basically
just to give an intuition of what i mean
it's mostly like repeating what i just
said
um
just you know writing a little bit in
formulas um
so
basically i mean we will again switch to
this view of counting the internal edges
because it's just a little bit more
convenient here uh so the cut value of
any
of union of two sets s on the left hand
side and t on the right hand side is
essentially this is the sum of the
degrees on the left hand side
plus the sum of the degrees on the right
hand side
minus the number of internal edges
number of internal edges is can be
viewed as you're iterating over all
vertices on the left hand side and
counting the neighborhood the
intersection of the neighborhood of this
of the string s i with the set t
so
let me let me define a phi as being this
um
the number of the number of edges
between the set t and a particular
node si
right i call this a5
so what bob does it chooses s but
maximize this sum
right
so
again kind of intuitively if there is no
approximation
right if if all these works with no
approximation then bob will really
choose all the eyes that that are
essentially maximalify
and
just because of our conditioning that
you know let's say if we consider a
closed situation um where this delta is
less than n by half minus r
um when this
f i is
is more than the average in some sense
so it should be
in the first half of uh of ice
okay so okay let me um
this is what we need to prove uh let me
just kind of explain this again so think
about this uh
just repeating what i said um so think
about these advice right we choose a set
s of size half of of how many edges were
on the left-hand side right so this is
basically means that we'll choose all
the i's that are in the first 50
percentile of all these counts
okay
and each of these phi is distributed as
binomial distribution
okay
there is some error
right and this is why it is not obvious
kind of uh namely that we compute this
up to one perception approximation error
which in total gives us an additive of n
to 1.5
value
so
um
so kind of
thoroughly we have some sense we have
this line these are these counts of phi
and we have a bunch of them here
and kind of somewhere here which is n by
four uh is the expectation and we are
kind of distributed
kind of around this value and uh what we
want to say that
um the if if some i is close
basically
in other sense this this fi is is larger
than the expectation then it should be
on the on this side
and it should be in this in roughly in
the first first 50th percentile of ice
okay so let me
tell this uh differently a little bit so
let me consider a set l
uh of uh index indices i this is our
indices on the left hand side uh such
that f i um
you know the number of edges between i
and and my set t is bigger than uh the
expectation plus standard deviation
okay note that uh these are exactly eyes
such such that if k is equal to i then
the answer should be close
this is the number of edges which is
kind of the negative of a distance so
this means that the distance is less
than
you know it should be on average minus
standard deviation
okay so
else are things which are kind of
average plus standard deviation
okay
uh so
if
just repeating the point i mentioned
before is that if there is no
approximation that k is in l if and only
if it is close
right just because of all the
concentration
um
but
still
uh we've approximation it has to be the
case that 80 percent let's say of l must
be contained in the set s
so s i mean l in something's the ideal
set s is is is what we get by
approximation so 80 percent of l must be
contained in s with say 90 probability
because otherwise the approximation is
too large
right because obvious a constant
fraction of l which is roughly linear in
n
has to cross basically a standard
uh so this is n by 4 plus
standard deviation this is n by 4 minus
standard deviation so basically a
constant fraction of things have to
cross from here to here and the distance
here is standard deviation which is
roughly root 10 so the total error so if
this doesn't hold when the total error
should be around n to 1.5
which is not allowed because we have an
additive error of at most and 1.5
okay so
that finishes the lower one um
so let me just conclude um
again what what this talk was about is
about cut specifiers uh which has size
and by epsilon uh
i mean particular linear dependence on
one over epsilon under two relaxations
one is that the uh
this sketch is a is is not a graph but a
general data structure and two is that
uh
the the guarantees with high probability
per query per cut query
and also relaxation two is really
necessary otherwise we need n by epsilon
squared size
uh so let me mention a few
natural questions here so first one is
does the first relaxation is necessary i
mean maybe we can do um
these for each guarantee basically with
high probability just by using a graph
so using the normal estimate not this
kind of negative estimate
so just count the number of edges across
cut as opposed to some degrees minus
number of edges inside or maybe there is
a lower bound
um
question two is you know what are other
applications where this with high
probability estimate is actually
sufficient uh
in particular this seems to
definitely be usable in applications
where we just ask a
polynomial number of non-adaptive
queries
or say logarithmic number of adaptive
queries i guess um
um
and
part three is uh can we prove the same
guarantee for spectral specification and
uh
david dudrov with coffers uh show that
some improvement over one over epsilon
squared is possible so in particular we
obtain one over epsilon to 1.6
thank you